let's go next to Nelson from Bethlehem
Nelson from Bethlehem Bethlehem welcome
hey there David
um great show so far this week thank you
you've been killing like usual
appreciate that very much uh I don't
think anybody's touched on this yet
today so I wanted to get your opinion on
them I don't think I've seen it on your
show
um are you familiar with Daniel Ortega
down there in Nicaragua and the Sam
denistas
only superficially I don't have deep
knowledge
yeah they're um one of those groups that
you hear about a lot in the news but
never nobody ever really talks about
them um so back in September um Daniel
Ortega for anybody that doesn't know he
is
um like the one real communist leader
down there trying to um uh bring
socialism uh to South America
um again against the witches of the
United States
um in September he outlawed
um public displays of Christianity and
um about a month ago on Easter he went
and rounded up a bunch of journalists
and clergy members and um arrested a
bunch of people attending Catholic mass
now I'm an anti-theist I think that all
religion is bad and all of it needs to
be outlawed I just think he's being a
little heavy-handed with it
um I was having a discussion with some
of the chat members and a lot of them
are in favor I was just wondering um do
you think that we should um
like when it comes to it in the United
States uh do you think that people like
it should be a little bit more
heavy-handed against the Catholic church
and Christian religion or so here's the
thing okay there's two different layers
to this from the little let's talk about
the situation Nicaragua first and then
we'll talk more generally
it seems as though it's it the the goal
really is to actually go after political
opponents of Ortega under the guise of
this anti-religion stuff correct me if
I'm wrong but it seems that to some
degree they're not just randomly going
for the most part it doesn't seem like
they're randomly going after Catholics
but the idea is
targeting opponents of of Ortega is that
your understanding as well
um I would say 90 that is it but they're
also going after
um the normal people that are like out
blocking traffic with Easter parades and
stuff they're going after everyone's out
when that stuff is fair so that's an
important clarification my view is there
should be total separation of church and
state I don't ever want to hear
scripture cited by an elected official
during a debate about what the law
should be the way it's cited in the
United States about abortion about trans
issues about LGBT issues of all I never
want to hear that stuff I don't want to
see Ten Commandments displays at a
courthouse I I want separation of church
and state but
I also want freedom of religion which
includes
freedom to follow any religion or not
and not to be persecuted so to the
extent that the Catholic church has been
involved in child abuse cover-ups they
should receive absolutely no special
help whatsoever but to the extent that
you know being heavy-handed with just
people who go to church and worship just
because I don't do that doesn't mean
that I want the government going after
them so I I cannot in good conscience
support anything like that
okay well it's good to hear your opinion
on that and I would like to say as
another thing of clarification um it is
mostly political and a lot of it has to
go down to like racial lines because um
well a lot of the indigenous Community
down there is not Catholic and you know
it kind of bounces heads up against it
but thank you for giving your opinion on
that David I was just curious and uh
once again my brother's soft gentleman
is listening in the call-in show you
can't call in but love you out there
softly and love you so much David thank
you for doing what you do does that mean
is that like soft serve what does that
mean
no it's a nickname going back to when we
were in high school it's just the thing
that he did in theater class soft
gentlemen it's a long story oh boy I
hope it's uh appropriate for a PG
audience geez Nelson thank you very much
for the call it is okay good thank you
very much for the call and uh all right
let's continue let's go next to Ricardo
from one of my favorite cities
um I guess in North America uh Montreal
Ricardo welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
hello David how are you I'm doing well
good to hear hey uh I know that
um uh before I ask any questions
um I know this is something that
probably many in your audience have
asked you have asked you time and time
and again uh but it's actually more of a
comment but
um I think it would be great to to see a
debate between you and Ben Shapiro
sometime yeah well I'll do it anytime
we've invited him on the program and he
doesn't respond so he may be too big for
us now but uh he's welcome anytime I'm
glad to do that but it's he he's the one
you've got to convince not me
mm-hmm yeah of course yeah yeah uh but
yeah I remember uh some years back I
think maybe about 2019 I think I I
watched the uh the the debate between
you and Ben Benji are not sure if
there's any been any other debates I
think it was in 2013 you and then had
the debate but uh yeah I think that was
that was a good debate and I think yeah
in a way you you kind of like unraveled
his arguments especially about uh gun
gun control and all that
um but uh to tell you the truth I I know
that um uh when during the pandemic I
think the early stages pandemic when the
the whole George Floyd uh riots were
happening that's when I really started
like listening to you and mentioned
there was actually a period time when I
was listening to you both you and Ben
Shapiro just to sort of get like the
left perspective and the right
perspective on different things but I do
notice that uh over time it seems that
um his views on things got more and more
like extreme when he it seems that his
views kind of got more to the right I
don't know if you noticed that you know
I don't follow Shapiro super closely
but it does strike me that that entire
group Shapiro former actor Michael
Knowles Candace Owens they all seem to
have become dramatically more extreme
and I don't know if it's that they found
out that it's more profitable or
interesting or if they genuinely have
become more I I don't really know what
the reason is for it you know one of the
things that I've noticed is that my
political views have really not
dramatically changed over the last
decade and there's nothing right or
wrong with views changing if you get new
information you revise your views I
think that that's a really great thing
but it does strike me as odd
particularly based on their age you know
Dave rubin's another one who it's just
weird when at a certain age you have
such differing such changing views
because it suggests that your views as
an adult were already not super well
informed if they can change so radically
so it is kind of a weird thing
it is yeah I I agree 100
and I know that uh in the past you have
also talked about how uh Dave Rubin
probably like when he was in his 30s or
40s uh he suddenly went from being
liberal or on the left to on the right
and in some ways he's even kind of like
on the radical right uh Joe I think uh
like there was a time I was actually
listen uh just just out of curiosity the
sake I was listening to a interviewer he
was doing with I think it was Michael
Knowles and and there are some things
that Dave Rubin still had views on the
left of like on abortion he still I
think he still uh agree that abortion
should be accessible to all women and he
just said that he wasn't he wasn't like
ready yet to abandon that abortion
should be accessible so I thought that
was interesting
yeah you know the Dave Rubin thing is
really perplexing to me because he's 46
years old now and so he had this
complete political 180 at like age 38
let's call it that's like I mean think
think for a second Ricardo how crazy it
would be if right now right at my me
current at my current age at this point
in my career I became a right-wing
extremist like that would be would you
would you even believe that or would you
assume I'm doing it because I can do it
profitably like is it even viable that I
would completely 180 My Views right now
it seems so insane
yeah I I guess if you you were to do
that theoretically that would be that
would strike me as like oh what's going
on here was he did he even have left
wing views in the first place right or
or was I or Were My Views so poorly
grounded in reality that I didn't even
know what I believe I mean it would be
very weird when I think about it that
way now that I'm roughly the age that he
was when he did his thing it's really
strange it's it's really weird to
imagine
I agree it reminds me a bit of like how
uh you know when Trump was 60 and he
says oh yeah I saw a kid and and uh and
and you know what I I think I'm gonna be
against abortion
and honestly I think he was like 66 at
that point it's even it's even harder to
believe yep I I think it's all very
weird and I do think that they've moved
further to the right Ricardo
I agree yeah and uh even even Jordan
Peterson I I was sometimes it happens
that I'll listen to some of his like
podcasts and some of the I don't really
listen as much as I used to but I think
I feel like even he's become more
radical like oh yeah I think he had
somebody he said he had somebody on his
show and he was using the term globalist
I'm like oh shoot oh yes that's really
crazy no he's lost his mind it's it's
really crazy what's going on and
unfortunately it's been normalized to
where they're seen as kind of like not
that extreme but these are really
extreme people Ricardo I got a rap but I
really appreciate you being bringing
this up
yeah no problem by the way before I go
uh just one question is there any right
wing uh people you'd like to have a
debate with next
not really I mean I'll talk to I'll talk
to whoever but I'm not like pining to
debate them you know they're pretty bad
faith actors in general
yeah I agree well thanks for having me
on I really appreciate it all right
Ricardo from Montreal Quebec Canada
great to see you great to hear you
rather uh that's gonna do it for today
I'm sorry I couldn't speak to everyone
but we will take calls again have a
great weekend unless you've got access
to the bonus show in which case we'll
see you in a moment